Let's actually look at the whole
concept of aligning images, right.
First thing I can do is if I have
a pair of images left and right,
I can just translate the image on top
of each other, find similar features.
Just showcased here as long
as I can do a decent job of
aligning some of these things,
I might be fine but will I really be?
I mean, again, the options that I may
have in this kind of relationship is
I may be able to put
a left image on top and
the right image on the bottom and
do a best possible alignment that way.
Another option is I can put r, the right
image on top and the left on bottom and
you can see that now we can actually
start figuring out a little bit more
between these two images but in reality,
we need to be able to do a lot more.
In reality, what we need to do is be
able to kind of blend these images
together but before we do that,
we also have to warp the left and
right images and again,
this warp means now,
if you'll notice, is that the image
is no longer rectangular.
And, of course, what that basically
means is now we've been able to kind of
merge the regions that
similar across both images.
So warping, in this instance,
is a better solution and
again, now we know how
to do that kind of stuff